بائع نقانق بسجل اجرامي بات احد اقوى
شخصيات الكرملين يتحدى المؤسسه العسكريه
وينتقدها على نيه مره تلو الاخرى قائد
فادنار
نجح كبائع نقانق في مدينه بوتين
اوائل التسعينيات ليفتتح مطعما راقيا يدعى
ولحسن حظه بات مطعم الرئيس الروسي المفضل
اصبح بريكوجين يعمل على توصيل طلبات
الطعام وخدمات الضيافه لحفلات الكريملين
ومن ثم حفله عيد ميلاد بوتين عام 2003
فكسب لقب طباخ بوتين نجح الرجل في توسيع
دائره علاقاته داخل الكرمنين ليكتسب عقودا
حكوميه لتوفير الطعام للمدارس الروسيه
وللجيش الروسي فاصبح من اثرياء روسيا
ومع المزيد من الاموال تبدل نمط حياته
فاصبح يمتلك قصرا في سام
ويختن وطائره خاصه ومهبطا للطائرات
المروحيه
بدات علاقته معقده الجيش تتوتر في عام
2015 فتح الباب امام المنبوذين من الجيش
وحتى المساجين رواتب مغريه والحريه مقابل
سته اشهر من الخدمه في جبهه فاجنار تصرفات
اغضبت رئيس هيئه الاركان
ليعرقل فوز بريكوجين بعقود حصريه لتموين
الجيش منذ 2018
قبل اشهر اصدر البرلمان الروسي بتشجيع من
الجيش اصدر قانونا ينظم عمل شركات الخاصه
الا ان قائد فاجنر رفض القرار متسائلا عن
الهدف من تنظيم عمل شركه تدار بكفاءه
عاليه في العام الماضي قالت واشنطن ان ابن
بروجين بافل حارب مع باجنار في سوريا وحصل
على جائزه الصليب الاسود
في عده مناطق قتاليه حول العالم
ظهر مرتزقه بادنر اتهموا بتنفيذ الاعمال
القذره التي لا تريد موسكو التورط فيها
انكر بروجين علاقته بالشركه مرارا قبل ان
يعترف في سبتمبر العام الماضي بعد انخراط
المجموعه في حرب اوكرانيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات